Because we're lazy engineers, we're
going to take something that works,
a logistic classifier and do the minimal
amount of change to make it non-linear.
We're going to construct our new
function in the simplest way that we can
think of.
Instead of having a single matrix
multiplier as our classifier,
we're going to insert
a RELU right in the middle.
We now have two matrices.
One going from the inputs to the RELUs,
and
another one connecting
the RELUs to the classifier.
We've solved two of our problems.
Our function in now nonlinear thanks
to the RELU in the middle, and
we now have a new knob that we can tune,
this number H which
corresponds to the number of RELU
units that we have in the classifier.
We can make it as big as we want.
Congratulations, you've built
your first neural network.
You might ask, wait a minute,
where's my neuron?
In the past, when talking about neural
networks, I remember seeing diagrams
with dendrites, axons, activation
functions, brains, neuroscience.
Where is all that?